c'est une décomposition en fait de
certaines glandes qui provoquent des
odeurs un peu excessives
[Rires]
donc est-ce que vous pouvez
il y a une étude qui est sortie et qui
disent que d'après l'odeur de quelqu'un
peut être son ami ou pas c'est ça en
fait c'est un peu alors comme les
animaux c'est-à-dire que par exemple ou
comme les expressions il y a une
expression très courante qui dit
celle-là je la sens je la sens pas dit
souvent ça voilà et en fait suivant
certaines odeurs on va être attiré ou
non par les gens moi je trouve que ce
renifle pas c'est le trou de balle
je me dis que avant une réunion par
exemple non mais chéri on pourrait
installer ça avant avant chaque émission
on pourrait se tourner un peu autour et
tu verras qu'il y aurait des relations
qui deviendraient alors attendez le
docteur quoi effectivement c'est quelque
chose en fait on se sent quand on
rencontre des gens en général la
première chose qu'on fait c'est le
toucher et sentir les autres c'est à
dire que certaines odeurs vont nous
rassurer on nous rappeler des souvenirs
d'enfants c'est pour ça qu'on a chacun
un parfum et que chaque parfum peut
correspondre pas à quelqu'un madame
est-ce que vous pouvez nous sentir
est-ce que vous pouvez justement oui
voilà je vais bander les yeux des
chroniqueurs non d'ailleurs je vais vous
demander les yeux
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors vous allez donc sentir les
chroniqueurs
si vous sentez cette personne ce que
vous sentez alors après c'est alors ça
reste c'est particulier quand même voilà
et puis alors rien n'est précis
si on a pas envie de se faire sentir
par rapport à vous du coup en fait c'est
ça parce que moi je ne vous connaissais
pas entendre avec vous c'est pas ça elle
va donner aussi un petit peu voilà
personnalité vous pouvez sentir un
connard à travers l'odeur d'accord alors
vas-y allez-y docteur qui veut aller
rejoindre le docteur vent à queue
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un homme ça c'est sûr je sens
quelqu'un de très rustre un petit peu
en même temps
non je pense que vous êtes une très
bonne personne avec un grand cœur
sincèrement mais je pense qu'on peut
faire beaucoup la fête avec vous voilà
est-ce qu'on peut sentir autre chose
un deuxième sujet un deuxième sujet si
vous nous rejoignez il est 19h08 docteur
vent à queue qui est spécialiste voilà
avec l'odeur elle peut être capable de
savoir si elle peut être ami ou si elles
sont les choses oh là là disons
l'expression je sens quelqu'un ou je te
sens ouais alors on peut savoir si la
personne est cocue ou pas
[Rires]
je suis quelqu'un de très sensible et en
fait je sens simplement que vous êtes
une belle personne en tout cas
vous êtes gentil vous êtes généreux
pigeon mais effectivement j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes trop gentil
parfois et ben malheureusement j'ai
l'impression que vous faites manipuler
ou pas
malheureusement j'ai peur que parfois
vous fassiez manipuler ou tromper
j'ai bien fait de venir
elle connait pas l'émission qui peut y
aller qui veut y aller
je suis désolé hein
excusez-moi dites ce que vous sentez
après voilà je suis en train de dire
comment
[Musique]
ça sent très bon
vous êtes jeune vous êtes fraîche et je
pense que en amitié en tout cas
on peut vous faire confiance on peut
vous appeler que ce soit pour pleurer ou
pour faire la fête d'accord voilà merci
ce que je ressens merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
ça sent le fauve
elle est choquée
[Musique]
désolé ça sent très très fort le parfum
après je sais pas si c'est ce que c'est
comme parfum mais ça sent très fort
c'est négatif c'est quoi
en fait j'essaye de masquer quelque
chose c'est ça voilà bravo
je pense que en amitié c'est quelqu'un
de très bien mais je pense que parfois
c'est un peu trop
c'est dans l'extravagance on est dans
quelque chose de trop quoi ça fait un
peu tout much quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais alors encore une fois je suis
sincèrement désolé je pense qu'un amitié
c'est un peu lâche
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant c'est dingue
docteur vous êtes incroyable bravo tout
ce que vous dites
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup de confiance
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui cherche
c'est magnifique ça sent mieux
ah non ça sent l'homme ça se sent c'est
rustre
ah ouais alors ça c'est très rustre
mais alors c'est bizarre parce que je
peux me permettre de tourner votre
pardon
mais en même temps qui a un petit coeur
fragile
tu t'es suis avec quelle main
j'ai l'impression qu'un petit côté
féminin c'est la personne
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable tu as
un besoin de plaire mais on sait pas à
qui
incroyable
merci voilà merci merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
pour l'instant tout ce qu'elle dit c'est
incroyable
[Rires]
attention
assassin très très bon c'est une femme
c'est sûr ça sent très très bon c'est
quelqu'un qui est par contre très
minutieuse très professionnelle très en
amitié non amitié on peut je pense vous
êtes très fidèle Vous êtes quelqu'un sur
Quimper et qui est très droite dans la
vie et dans le professionnel voilà
c'est la première fois que va sentir une
personne décédée
c'est réalisé sans trucage regardez chez
vous il fait froid
[Rires]
c'est quelqu'un qui a disparu il y a de
ça 15 ans
alors effectivement alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est très positif c'est à dire que vous
êtes une inter très rassurante
effectivement alors c'est pas très dit
comme ça c'est pas positif mais en fait
ça l'est effectivement c'est une odeur
un peu d'enfance chez nos grands-parents
et ça nous rassure
merci
[Applaudissements]
du mal à faire le tour du
que c'est une femme
[Rires]
ah non
[Musique]
[Rires]
je pensais que c'est quelqu'un de bien
sincèrement
en toute honnêteté ça sent un peu
l'Oriental mais en vrai dans le bon sens
du terme c'est à dire qu'on a envie de
faire la fête avec nous
je sais pas qui c'est mais on a envie de
faire la fête avec vous et vous êtes
quelqu'un de très bon et très sensible
et très doux je pense au fond
mais vraiment c'est quelqu'un de très
très gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà ce qu'elle a dit sur toi c'est
complètement
je vais vous dire franchement formidable
[Applaudissements]